I've been the person who has found the
comfort of not having to rely on other
people always saying no to social
invites to the point where you no longer
need to say no creating a routine of
people not inviting you because they
know that you're going to say no also
alleviates the NOS that you have to say
in future it is so seductive and
enjoyable to go and do this thing but
the reason that you went to go and do
this isolation personal development
thing in the first place was to then
reintegrate into the world as a leveled
up higher Social market value more
competent person with this whole new
skill set and this degree of self-love
if you never actually bother to
reintegrate or if you even make it so
difficult to reintegrate because you
can't remember what it's like to not do
that it's dangerous something that can
be really really good in the first place
can end up being toxic at high doses
monk mode is one of those I would have
made life a little bit easier if I'd
just taken small breaks every six months
as opposed to doing these much bigger
Longer stretches where Breaking the
Habit becomes super rough